[Music]
maybe you've recently seen the phrase
gluten-free on food packaging or takeout
menus shampoo bottles apartment listings
the tag of your shirt on a hammer as a
lower-back tattoo or in your friends
resume next time someone starts telling
you about their newfound freedom from
gluten here are some questions you can
ask and the well-informed answers that
your friend being a reasonable
individual making educated dietary
choices and by no means just following
the latest diet craze will tell you what
is gluten gluten is an insoluble protein
composite made up of two proteins named
gliadin and glutenin
where might you encounter gluten gluten
is found in certain grains particularly
wheat rye and barley
what has gluten been doing for the
previous entirety of human history and
why do you suddenly care about it lutein
is responsible for the elastic
consistency of dough and the chewiness
of foods made from wheat flour like
bread and pasta for some people these
foods cause problems namely wheat
allergy celiac disease and non-celiac
gluten sensitivity
wheat allergy is an uncommon condition
that occurs when a person's immune
system mounts an allergic response to
Limp proteins leading to my own problems
and in rare cases a potentially
dangerous reaction called anaphylaxis
celiac disease is an inherited disease
in which eating foods with gluten leads
to inflammation and damage of the lining
of the small intestine this impairs
intestinal function leading to problems
like belly pain bloating gas diarrhea
weight loss skin rash phone problems
like osteoporosis iron deficiency small
stature infertility fatigue and
depression
untreated celiac disease increases the
risk of developing certain types of
cancer celiac disease is present in one
in every 100 to 200 persons in the u.s.
when blood tests just the possibility of
celiac the diagnosis is confirmed with a
biopsy the most effective treatment is a
gluten-free diet which helps heal
intestinal damage and improve symptoms
some people don't have celiac disease or
a wheat allergy but still experience
symptoms when they eat foods with gluten
these people have non-celiac gluten
sensitivity they experience painful gut
symptoms and suffer from fatigue brain
fog joint pain or skin rash a
gluten-free diet typically helps with
these symptoms so how many people
actually have this gluten sensitivity
you speak of gluten sensitivities
occurrence in the general population is
unclear but likely much more common than
wheat allergy or celiac disease
diagnosis is based on the development of
symptoms the absence of wheat allergy
and celiac disease and subsequent
improvement on a gluten-free diet
there's no reliable blood or tissue test
partly because gluten sensitivity isn't
a single disease and has a number of
different possible causes for example it
may be the case that gluten can activate
the immune system in a small intestine
or cause it to become leaky but
sometimes people claiming gluten
sensitivity are actually sensitive not
to wheat proteins but sugars found in
wheat and other foods called frucht
hands the human intestine can't break
down or absorb fruit dense so they make
their way to the large intestine or
colon where they're fermented by
bacteria producing short chain fatty
acids and gases this leads to unpleasant
symptoms in some people with bowel
problems another possible explanation
behind human sensitivity is the nocebo
effect this occurs when a person
believes something will cause problems
and because of that belief it does it's
the opposite of the more well-known and
much more fortuitous placebo effect
given how much bad press Putin is
getting in the media the nocebo response
may play a role for some people who
think they're sensitive to gluten
for all these reasons it's clear that
the problems people develop when they
eat wheat and other grains aren't
exclusively due to be so a better name
than non-celiac gluten sensitivity might
be wheat intolerance
[Music]